uveon says you get trashed regularly by
that
kid on the progressive voice he just
trashed you for a million views
i think the infighting is silly what are
your thoughts i have no idea yeah i
don't um i mean as you guys know i don't
uh
really watch too much like left tube
content
but that's funny um i mean listen i
don't know what he's saying
but um if people don't like me
that's fine if they don't like if i'm
too left or too right for them you know
every day i get uh we we
at this point we get about 5 000
messages a day
across that that includes you know
twitter reddit
facebook youtube comments emails all of
this different stuff
and of the 5 000 every day there's
dozens that say i'm a centrist
shill i'm not really a progressive and
there's dozens that say i'm a far-left
communist marxist
and of course as you all know i'm just a
northern european social democrat
i'm not northern european i just mean
i'm in sort of that that political
mindset but you know one of the things i
would say is
um if there if there are people who are
focused focusing instead of
issues on just attacking other left
channels i do think that it is a waste
of time from a practical standpoint and
you guys know that there's a lot of
grifters on the left
and right but you know i'm concerned
about the ones on the left
who um instead of really like generating
ideas
and content and putting out uh
putting out their perspective there's a
lot of just stupid infighting
and uh i i would i would caution people
away from that i don't i don't think
it's useful
and you know the truth is again i don't
know specifically what people are
referring to here but
there's also a lot of jealousy in this
community which is why you know with our
million subscriber video
which was just congratulations from a
lot of different people and you know we
talked to sam cedar in this video jenk
yuger sent the clip
arian foster former nfl running back who
has a great show
anthony mellon fantano we heard from
benjamin dixon
uh nomi khan then former producer lewis
you know all these great people
hassan [ __ ] cresson destiny [ __ ] ii
levy rosman from the chess community
we've heard from
farron cousins and uh attorney mike pap
antonio who else did we hear from we
heard from stephen kenneth as you can
see you know all these different people
um so what so what you know i i've
deliberately
got people who are not
basing their relationships with me off
of we agree off of whether we agree on
every issue that's stupid
it's a waste of time just what are we
doing you know
uh in the long run we're all dead are we
really gonna waste our time with this
stuff
anyway let's continue i i you know
i'm thrilled that we're at a million
youtube subscribers and i'm excited for
other people to get there as well
other than the young turks who got there
before me even if we don't get
um even if we don't agree on every
single issue
period end of story done so okay my
friends
that's i think all we're gonna do in
terms of uh in terms of that negativity